my number one networking tip is to be
the most interested person rather than
trying to be the most interesting person
but it always starts with providing
value because the law of reciprocity is
so unbelievably real and nobody is going
to want to help you if they're just
meeting you for the first time and
you're asking for something right off
the bat I spent at least 15 minutes of
my day providing value to people whether
that is sharing people's content
commenting on their stuff going and
writing reviews for my friends books or
my friend's podcasts and sharing that
review with them and sharing the review
with my followers everybody needs help
with something thing if you want to make
a connection or a relationship with
somebody figure out how you can help
them